Not another video, please.
I can't fucking do this shit anymore.
anymore
It's been 84 years
Please release me from this curse
I don't want to act like an retard online anymore.
Okay
One more
How is it going bros? Ma name is PewDiePie!
Welcome to... Muddy Heights 2!
In this game you poop.
Think of the most attractive person in the world
I know I'm right in front of you.. but the second one most attractive
That person poops
Now I want you to imagine that person pooping
*crickets*
I realize you're probably having a seizure right now.
Don't worry, I'm going to keep playing, just make sure you don't bite your toungue
alright
We got a new level
We're at the beach now
We got people on seaways
We got people in pools
There's babies... we can poop on babies
and hot babes
Okay, so we're just sitting in the lounge. Having a nice relaxing day
But suddenly...
WE HAD TO TAKE A SHIT
*savage music* / RIP people with headphones
FUCK YEAH
hit the ring, hit the ring
YEEAAH haha
Hole in one bebe
Oh, man wa- It's so nice 2 be a poop
I think i'll go to the biash
Can we poop on the duck - 26 year old
That wuss a good shit
Let's try and hit the jaqutzie
Cam on, come on... comon
ohw the muscle builders
*Bible*
YEEAAHH
Nice and steamy
*sex sounds*
Why does no one love me
I have one question actually.........
Y does the poop... make poop noises
Does the poop have it's own butthole?
I am legit churros abt this
*sad beats*
*fart*
Hey guys can I dance with you
Y does the woMAN scream like a man - Pewds 2016
Not that I would confirm to any gender stereotypes - sure pewds
No, really, please... don't... post... a tumblr
I'm sorry. I just thought
Iffs he's wearing a bikini
How could I have known. HAUW.. COULD I...HAVE..KNOOOHOWN
Well that's the end of my yt career. I fukked up.
Oh, hey Dj (tanner)
Fuck Yeah. I'm the DJ now.
Mr. Dj Khali-oh. On this mix board.
*DJ Khaled music* - ANOTHERONE
One of them is actually a pice of shit and the other one is as well.
Let's see if we can hit that baby doing backflips, cuz he's pissing on me
*music*
FUCK
Should we do  a shitty,  this is SPARTA meme
I think we should do a shitty this is Sparta meme
THIS.. IS.. SPAARTA
I backed out last minute. I'm sorry
I think the baby is dead.  I think I killed the baby.
*Ethan Bradbury*
Let's see if we can make it to the ocean.
Come on to the ocean, bebe
Get the fuck outta my way, lady
Get away bucket.
Yessssea logging.
Can we make it to the boat?
come o- NNOOO
YES, we made it.
Captain Poop
*RRrr ya ready kidz? aai, aai captain*
I can't hearr yuuuu? AAI, AAI CAPTAIN.
Look at this guy, enjoying his day.
You just got sunscreen bebe.
Now here is a question, I never thought I would ask.
Can poop climb ladders?
Sorda... Hehe. The answer is sorda
Wa- he... How do I? Come on
Swere I belong guys.
The trash
Let's try higher jump
We gotta get all toiletpaper bros... come on
O man We jump hiiigh
Yeeeaaah, gimme that toilet paper
WOEW
Can we climb this ladder?
Man i-i've underestimeted, the struggles of being a pice of shit
I'm hidin..
No one will find me, no one expects a pice of shit to hide
COME ON... COME-.-
YES, OMG. I had 5 poop crumn- I have 2 poop monocles left*
*fart*
Oh
Explode with ''f'''. We're gonna bomb the fuck outta this pool.
This pool... is gonna taste the Pewdieepie fury
OOOÓOHOO.0OOO0..... ho
Come on, bebe
Missing one toilet paper
Look at us, up there, just taking a shit.
So classy
Where is the last toiletpaper?
You must be under here
*weird ass music*
Oh, I saw it. I think I saw it.
There it is. Oh my God, yes
Mom.. mom I'm coming back. I'm coming home mam.
Ahw, it's so kawaii, so kawaii poor guy
That guy look's like... poop went inside him
Can we play wit the basketball?
Oh, we can. Amazing... I am having the time of my life
*Time of my lyfe song*
Alright...That was poop game 2016..marie heitz
Check out this game, see if you can beat my highscore
What is it? What is my highscore?
Download this game. Post a screenshot if you beat my highscore.
I will send you my shit.. *sigh* Pewdiepie
Thank you bros soo much for green lighting this game. I think that's real cool of you.
And as always... stay awsome bros*brofist*
*Outro*